[Applause]
[Music]
right guys it's good to see we're gonna
learn something really exciting about
circles today and I love circle circles
are everywhere very very useful shapes
you find them in nature not just in
things that we create so we're gonna
measure some circles today and I want to
discover something really surprising
about it now so you're gonna need one of
these we're gonna do some measurement
with this tree and I this this frying
pan looks like a pretty good circle so
build your own this up and there's a
nice big circle there on the pan can you
measure all the way around and can you
take those ends and now why don't you
lay them against this room so what might
because all the way up - yeah what are
you getting 77 nicely done okay thank
you very much and then with the same pan
can you measure all the way across so
this is we called the diameter and what
are you getting when you measure a cross
when you put against the ruler plate
full point by 245 very nice okay so we
need another circle um you know I'm
Eddie you look roughly circular Billy
don't try and measure and that is head
sir be gentle okay all the way around
the forehead that's it
all right we can use the same rule up
here we go what's that like 15 okay she
said I was around right now to get
across and maybe go over the top nicely
done
okay go all the way make sure you get
the whole width so what are you getting
it's about seven eight seventy seven
okay now I want you to grab these
calculators of yours
okay now Maddie you measured these two
numbers what I'd love you to do is to
divide them together and Billy can do
the same but for your numbers three
point one and three point one and what
are usually three point one now hold on
a second we measured these different
kinds of circles different sizes but we
got this same pattern and this number
three point one you could actually take
you know teeny tiny circles like this or
you should take a circle like say the
equator around the earth you're always
gonna get this same number it's kind of
cool right and it's surprising as well
for me this is one of the things I love
about mathematics it kind of shows how
everything's interconnected all these
different circles you can see you've got
these circles all kind of nested within
each other and it's not just you know in
things that we make also in nature if
you have a look at this onion right you
can see you've got these layers and
these are these rings of the onion are
also concentric and if we measured
around we measured across we're still
going to get that same connection no
matter whether we got a big one or a
small one with beginning the same ratio
and this number it's so important it's
actually got some more decimal places
after we give it a name we call it pi
which is a Greek letter well actually so
these concentric circles show us how
mathematics really gives us the
connections between Billy Billy go well
thanks to men
what sort of eventually going on today
but Billy that's with mr. woo is an
adventure after all pure mathematics is
the poetry of logical ideas
[Music]
welcome Billy we are the fun guys our
presentation is about to commence
please remain attentive hey fun guys
there's not much room in here am i right
many apologies extra seating would act
as surplus to our regular requirements
please stand and observe the
presentation begins for billions of
years we fun guys have been bringing
efficiency balance and order to the
earth we work inside route soil and stem
opening pathways to nutrition in
exchange for carbon we also install and
maintain a communication network that's
used to share information about oncoming
danger whoa I thought you guys were
mainly just good and salads and pies yes
also pasta and soup it has come to our
attention that this onion patch is
overdue for a mycelium Network upgrade
we've had several unconfirmed reports of
parasitic ear worms in the surrounding
soil our data shows they may need to
activate their natural enzyme defense
systems however the few network nodes we
have managed to install have been
misappropriated or vandalized Billy we
need you to convince these onions to
connect they could be in serious danger
I'm sorry but they seem pretty happy
where they are why can't you just zap
down there and so the muni k was
yourself we follow rhizomatic growth
patterns Billy as such we exist as a
non-hierarchical process that binds soil
and stem to life through a continual
state of becoming so you're not gonna
sell them the cables we have no interest
in persuasion only organic connection
action is either taken or not taken and
it has become apparent that now is the
time for
a little help
brah um there are some fun guys
he wants you to reconnect to these
mycelium tube thingy apparently there
could be some ear worms coming your way
not likely brah we're chill uh are you
sure those fun guys don't know squat
dude they're always talking about
balance and connection but maybe I don't
want to be connected to the grid man see
how each of my circles is beautiful and
distinct um yes it's very nice why would
I want to go plug into the tube and zap
my circles under you want let me ask you
something mr. fun guy patrol what shape
is the planet huh it's circles dude just
like me
look around you this is a battery ah
Cuba man if you can hear me can you
please get me out of here
remember Billy mathematics since the
poetry of logical ideas I just really
want to get home and make some mushroom
pie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations Billy you saved those
volatile onions and helped to restore
the balance the fun guys aren't really
much for victory parties but as a reward
they gave me the coordinates to find the
freshest mushrooms for your pie and you
might like to breathe through your mouth
for a bit
are you okay Billy you look like you've
been crying
where am I we're in a mushroom farm
welcome
Oh can this day get any we know fall how
come the plants were with their son
black actually Billy it might surprise
you to learn that genetically mushrooms
are most similar to humans and plants no
way yes indeed way plants possess
chlorophyll and they grow via
photosynthesis the mushrooms break
things down for their food a bit like us
these are the guys are eating compost we
keep a roof on the whole environment to
make sure that they are nice and warm
and safe so it needs to be dark for them
to grow they prefer dark and coolant and
moist environments but they can survive
in the light too
they're very resilient in fact mushrooms
were some of the first complex life
forms on earth who are you I'm Stefan a
mushroom enthusiast and I'm here to help
you find the freshest mushrooms co-pi
OOP I um are you human
you could say that
I guess wait your mushroom enthusiast -
actually I'm a mushroom grower do you
want to learn yeah you ready to get your
hands dirty
grab some compost so this is how
mushroom start have a good smell so it's
got straw it's got water how another big
big smell can you smell the chicken poo
yeah it's got lots of chicken poo in it
as well so once we've made the compost
you'll be getting them and put the spawn
so spawns like the seed of mushroom well
there's like saying it's cool isn't it
then what we do is we blend that's true
it's pretty much like making a cake then
once the takes almost ready we've got it
I said so we get this peat moss and the
peat moss we put onto the bed and we add
water to it so when we add the water it
helps grow the mycelium through the peat
and then once that comes through we get
little beautiful little pins and once
the pins start forming they double in
weight overnight so if you imagine
you've got a little mushroom like this
and the next day it's even bigger and
gets bigger and bigger and then if you
see here see other mysoline there and
the mushroom yep yeah that's pretty cool
huh yeah have you ever picked a mushroom
before no wanna give it a go oh you want
that one swish the mushroom like that
and pick it you can snap the mushroom
open and hear that crunch yeah
and have a good smell what's it smell
like
earthy earthy inhabit a lush and sweet
isn't it you have first way to eat them
is raw I didn't know you could eat them
raw you can you can eat them raw or you
cook come come up that's why they're so
great
what about leaves are they the same or
are they different they're the exact
same but this mushroom here is just
stayed on the growing bed a bit longer
than this one so I picked this one as a
cup and this one's got picked as a flat
so what mushroom would I use if I wanted
to make a fire you could use any
mushrooms to make a pie you know the
best thing to do is your blender so you
can use all types and it makes the
flavor even better these are nice and
sweet and these are nice and strong
flavored and you know what they're all
hand-picked then we take the spent
compost and we put it back to the earth
it's like everything's connected like a
big circle Billy you've got to stop
doing that
Madi I get it now get what everything is
interconnected everything is everything
okay wait what's in your head pie
[Applause]
you